So the answer is none of the above and we'll
see why in a minute. First I want to mention
that all of these are sort of real words. It's
not that well defined what it means for something to be
a word. The first one is the longest word used
by Shakespeare. This is 27 letters long and it means
roughly, with honor. The second one is one letter longer.
It means the movement against the division of church and state.
The third one, which is 35 letters long,
means fear of long words. You can see it's
made up of phobia, which is fear and a
really big sort of made up root about things
being big and words. So it's fear of long
words. The fourth one is the longest word in
most large dictionaries. It's a kind of lung disease
that you get from having contact with volcanic particles.
So, the reason the answer is none of the above
is that I'm very confident whatever you claim is the longest
word, I can alwauys make a bigger one. There is
no such thing as the longest word in the English language.